from morning coffee to afternoon tea
caffeine is so thoroughly entrenched in
our daily routines and has become the
world's most widely used psychoactive
substance caffeine is a chemical
compound that stimulates the central
nervous system it accomplishes this by
attaching itself to adenosine receptors
in the brain in doing so it blocks
adenosine molecules which are
responsible for slowing down the central
nervous system before we sleep the
result
adenosine cannot regulate and neurons
start firing this results in a person's
reduced fatigue and increased alertness
and cognitive performance side effects
many seek by consuming caffeine caffeine
occurs naturally in coffee beans tea
leaves cacao beans and some tree nuts
people have been consuming it for
centuries but daily consumption took off
sporadically at different times in
different places around the world coffee
became popular in the 15th and 16th
centuries but cacao was used among early
Mesoamerican civilizations hundreds of
years earlier tea became popular by the
14th century in China during the Ming
Dynasty but didn't catch on in Britain
until almost 400 years later today
caffeine can be found nearly everywhere
and more and more caffeine infused
products are hitting the shelves every
day in the United States nearly 90% of
the population has at least one
caffeinated beverage every day
up to 400 milligrams of caffeine per day
or about four cups of coffee is
considered safe for an adult too much
caffeine for any one person can cause
side effects such as migraines insomnia
nervousness and muscle tremors one
tablespoon of pure caffeine equivalent
to drinking seventy five cups of coffee
at once can have lethal consequences due
to this risk of caffeine overdoses in
2018 the United States Food and Drug
Administration banned the bulk sale of
products containing pure or highly
concentrated caffeine while caffeine may
provide great benefits such as increased
focus alertness and energy it comes with
considerable risks just like any other
substance
[Music]